let's move on to rocky the annual
enrollment period for medicare is coming
to a close and rocky
has got some great information for us
she is live with select health who's
hosting a
phone bank to help answer your questions
hey there rocky take it away
hey mercedes and jc yeah it's a little
quiet in here because we're just getting
started i know the phone number is right
there on the crawl for select help so
everybody
is answered it's prepared to answer your
questions because open enrollment is
over
december 7th we're getting down to the
bar right that's right
we're almost there so just introduce us
to select health who are you guys and
what do you do for the community
well select health is part of what we
call an integrated health system
we are in partnership with intermountain
health care and our mission is to help
people live the healthiest lives
possible we offer medicare advantage
plans to medicare beneficiaries seniors
here in the community
oh and i just heard there's no number in
the call so let me give you that number
right now before we continue
if you guys want to 725-223-8433 calling
in right now and my second question is
when is the annual enrollment period for
medicare explain that because that's
that's the money question right yeah
that's a popular question
it runs from october 15th through
december 7th so although there is a bit
of time left
it's important to take a look at your
coverage and get started right away so
that you can be done with your
application by december 7th
and what are some of those important
considerations people should start
thinking about when it comes to
medicare advantage plans and all of the
complicated things
there's a whole bunch to consider and i
think the most important thing to
remember is that you've got to choose a
plan that's right for you
right for your situation right for your
medications your doctors that you like
to see
and i find that people should review
their medical coverage each year just to
make sure that they're on the best plan
for their situation
and the one that changes the most is the
prescription coverage you'll see that
some years the prescriptions are
affordable
and then all of a sudden they're much
more expensive and so it's a good idea
to review your prescription coverage
each year and make sure you're on the
best plan for your situation
okay well thank you so much mark and
select health for everything that you
guys are doing start calling that number
is 725-223-8433 the phone blake closes
at seven
and we'll be back here in the four send
it back to you guys thanks rocky i'm
watching everyone answering the phones
it looks like everyone is on the phone
right now so that is a good thing let's
keep them busy
and we'll check back in with you in the
in the four o'clock newscast